alors où en sommes nous avec cette
pandémie d'un point de vue international
avec nous de vie de docteur david
nabarro envoyé spécial de l'om est
chargé d'analyser l'épidémie du corps
navire le docteur nabarro bonjour
bonjour aux beaux jours
on doit tous les canadiens merci alors
oui alors nous allons aussi
géographiquement si vous le voulez
est-ce qu'on a raison de penser qu en
asie
c'est vraiment stabiliser qu'en europe
ou s'approche du pic du fameux sommet
est qu en amérique et du sud ou trois
semaines on va y arriver
je pense que vous avez raison c'est
comme ça on a choisi de soude est
brive s'est stabilisé et on a un
problème en europe où les cas sont
d'augmenter peut-être commence à trouver
le plateau et en amérique du nord dès
spécialement états unis chat au monde
mais il faut que je vous dise que
vraiment on agit de ce test
ça va revenir il faut que tous les pays
sont préparés pour le retour du bios et
pour qu'il dise pas au c'est fini non ça
peut revenir et c'est pour ça que je te
dis à tout le monde on peut pas dire que
c'est fini on peut dire qu on est au
milieu de gros épidémie il faut surtout
pas envoyer le message que c'est terminé
c'est ça vous vous levez exact exact
faut toujours avoir un défense au niveau
du communiqué le problème le plus
important avec cette vive hausse
est-ce qu'il est très très vite à
propager et si on n'est pas avec
beaucoup beaucoup d'attention ils
peuvent venir un très très gros
épidémique très vite comme on a à ce
moment à new york et je vois que je dise
à tous les pays s'il vous plaît vers les
banques défense avant bon santé publique
quand vous avez appris au canada avec ça
en 2003 il faut avoir une très bonne
défense au niveau de cumul était avec ça
en vain
mais notre nabarro ce que les gens se
pose comme question c'est que une fois
qu'on va avoir atteint les sommets dans
toutes les sociétés dans tous les pays
et qu'on va commencer à relâcher la
pression sur le confinement qui va
vendre stratégie de relâchement comment
on fait pour vivre une année une année
et demie avec un virus qui va continuer
à se promener
oui c'est pour ça que c'est très
important les questions que vous avez
demandé parce que il faut relâcher tous
ces restrictions et pour paravent
confinement pour les prochaines un ou
deux ans il faut avoir ce tempo relâcher
ces relâchements graduelle et avec ça on
peut recommencer la vie commençait
l'économie doit commencer l'emploi et
comme on sait tout mais on ne peut pas
le faire avant connard les défenses dont
un haut niveau de fiabilité datar donnez
moi une idée de l'échelle de temps
voudrait-il faut pas aller trop vite on
a compris alors prenons géographiquement
l'asie a commencé à relâcher l'europe
l'autriche a commencé à relâcher
certains pays à quel moment donné moins
une idée là pas d'absolu ménines des du
tad qu'est ce qu'on a devant nous on
peut regarder les autres payent dans
l'épée de rachid asie du sud est
ils ont besoin peut-être deux ou deux
ans entre deux et trois mois pour avoir
les systèmes qui sont assez forts les
défenses qui sont faux ils ont diminué
l'épidémie est maintenant ils ont qu'est
ce que ce que dit un styliste et peut
être préparée pour le virus mais si on a
tous les choses ensemble dans le pays à
ça peut être en deux ou trois mois mais
si on n'a pas tous les pièces de leur
riposte
ça peut être plus longue je peux pas
dire un pet commun combien de temps mais
on a regardé les paye et on a trouvé que
entre 2 et 3 - si tout va bien ils ont
encore comment ces opérations en europe
à ce moment bon alors par exemple
on a commencé le 13 prenant une date le
13 ou le 12 mars l'a vraiment avec
mesures de confinement avril mais ça
nous amène à la mi mai pour ce qui est
du canada donc ça vous paraît
raisonnable ça vous paraît réaliste
moi il me - je voudrais pas d'ailleurs
les situations hbo canada c'est la
diffusion locale mais de deux ou trois
mois
si on a tous les pièces ensemble
d'acteurs n'a baruya la science mais à
la politique n'est jamais loin
je vous montre un tweet du président
américain qui viennent twitté loup m s a
tout gâché
pour une raison quelconque elle est
financée en grande partie par les états
unis mais très centré sur la chine nous
allons y jeter un coup d'oeil mais
heureusement j'ai rejeté très tous leurs
conseils sur l'ouverture de nos
frontières avec la chine ce qu'il
ils vous accusent d'avoir concept de lui
avoir conseillé de ne pas fermer la
frontière avec la chine
qu'est ce que vous savez de ça et qu'est
ce que vous pouvez dire sur la gestion
de cette thèse par monsieur droit merci
beaucoup
maintenant mes yeux sont en impose je
regarde la bannière on est au milieu
d'une bataille et nombre et nomma entre
les gens humaines et autres si le virus
et sa demande l'attention du tout il
faut que tout le monde le chef tous nos
états travaillent ensemble que avec un
direction contre le virus et pour le
fautif dp candil face sur le virus je
avis de l' oms cédait être très très
rapide et fort quand le virus arrive il
faut que ça c'est le premier chose qu'on
fait comme cette pandémie est finie on
aura beaucoup des gens qui vont les
échos qui vont faire les histoires les 5
est trouvé qu'ils avaient bien qui a pas
fait bien mais ça c'est après c'est pas
pour maintenant on est au milieu d'une
guerre pour tout le monde et si on est
milieu d'une guerre on prend pas le chef
général et on dit toi tu as fait les
baisers re au milieu de ces guerres on
le fait après david docteur david
nabarro envoyé spécial de l'om est
chargé d'analyser l'épidémie de
coronavirus merci de nous avoir parlé
vous êtes près de genève bien sûr merci
de nous avoir parlé puis effectivement
les les analyses les enquêtes les blâmes
on va avoir largement le temps de tout
faire ça après puis on le fera bien sûr
google tribus et merci à la prochaine
c'est très apprécié et nous avons parlé
merci beaucoup à tous les canadiennes
vous êtes pris mon les leaders dans ce
type de l'udc
merci beaucoup pour tout tout tout votre
cauvin et votre appui c'est extrêmement
c'est très bon merci merci à doctor